thank you
hey everyone
welcome
Scribner the librarian I'd be log hi
House of conflict hi tolly
thank you thank you and I was able to
convince old Scribner that I had so much
I'm Michael thetical hi Brian
it's good how are you guys
I'm not sure what I did so how did
how did you well I suspect it's a matter
of differing opinions
she thinks I should still getting the
hang of this uh streaming stuff on the
other hand I'm inclined to disagree oh
just one moment I subscribe to lucky
lucky
self quite a sight isn't it thank you
thank you you certainly don't see that
every day
[Music]
I only have two characters and each of
them ended up being slytherins which is
a bit boring but absolutely that's how
she goes
to the left bin Forest yeah I'm not good
at gaming so definitely not doing hard
difficulty hence the name
how many uh hours have you guys are
logged on the game
ah you can see Hawks me just past those
ruins up ahead
have you had much of a chance to explore
the castle
a little it's positively enormous
it is that I've been there five years
and barely scratched the surface loads
to see places to discover
oh and you'd like to share with the
class
perhaps I think it's going to take me a
long time to beat the game because I'm
just I'm looking at everything you still
haven't told me how you became so good
this is my second character
but I still haven't played that much to
be honest
I've always thought thestral's pulling a
carriage a bit grin
though I suppose most people don't
actually see them at all
but you can see them
unfortunately
but you've seen quite a bit yourself
firsthand too
most notably that dragon attack
hopefully the rest of your year isn't as
eventful no spoilers
yeah I don't need to rush through the
game that's not really what I want to do
Mr Moon
he's the Hogwarts caretaker looks a bit
worse for where
hello Mr moon have you missed our new
fifth year I'm gonna try and make
content on the game as I go as well so
if I'll slow it down and then run
is everything all right sir
they're right at me eyes bigger
Pegasus
what did Mr Moon
does anyone know if it's possible to
change the field of view on a PS5 I
don't think it's possible
one can hope
I don't know what he's putting in his
pumpkin juice and he's obviously had too
much of it
I've never seen Mr moon in such a state
if you guys uh like the streams then
please give it a like so I know to keep
doing them
she is or rather she was yeah she's not
well at the moment but she'll be better
soon and back at home
honestly if one could Buckle them yeah
that's all I'm that's my only complaint
so far is the field of view thing
there's just something that holds me
we'll flock to it like moths to a flame
I wish I was centered on the screen and
I wish I was zoomed out a bit
so how would you like to do this Weasley
told me you had a list of things to get
gonna get the ones some other bits
yes Destiny seeds some spell crafts and
some potion recipes perfect can't wait
to see what you do with a new wand
and a short list gives you plenty of
time to poke around the village I just
have to pop into a shop to find
something for my sister let's meet up in
the town circle when you're finished
remember have fun it's hogsmead
I'm Ellen
foreign
apparently
who do we have here
hi Nitro Ace hi hexa I'll be right with
um
just a moment please
hi green pancake
ah hello sir I'm looking for a new wand
yes it's about time yes I about time
well you're our new fifth year student
are you not oh what am I saying of
course you are gerbold olivanders the
name but of course quite a few videos on
this guy I'm sure Timeless one makers in
the world it's a pleasure
truly
you were the perfect one shall we
oh no no not you
um ah House of conflict yeah that's uh
that's definitely the plan
powerful I wanna
make some more progress on the game and
then that'll be the next the next step
hi Tony
my Darth Revan
well go ahead swish
bye Solomon
odd once oh come on really sweet
oh dear
well this isn't a good match at all is
it
um
we'll find you something not to worry
if you guys want to learn more about the
wand that you got in the game then check
out my video the history of ones
it explains the Lang the chords the
words Dragonheart string the flexibility
let's give this one a try
oh goodness
looks like it's back to the shelf for
you no I didn't link my account
I'll probably do that with a different
character anticipated
where are you perhaps you ah
there you are
yes curious
yeah
take it
[Music]
not bad
curious indeed
it's
what do you think
this is my second character I haven't
played through the entire game on any
character
I'm not very far in on the other one
either
is it Canon
um
I'm still deciding
depends it's definitely more Canon than
the cursed child different
and it doesn't contradict some kind
anything in each the main storyline so
particularly I'd like to think of it as
Canon the right wand but I think that's
up to everyone's discretion learn from
it I'm eager to try us out I would
imagine so I'm certainly going to talk
about it like this
I will make the distinction magic and
the bond between you and your wand
thanks Tony only grow stronger do not be
surprised at your new one's ability to
perceive your intentions
particularly in a moment of need that
sounds wonderful Mr Ollivander I'll let
you get to it do come and see me again
if ever I can be of further assistance
beautiful
look at that wand
thanks face roller
I'll go in here I suppose
I'll do this afterwards
terms and Scrolls
foreign
still getting the hang of the controls
I'm not used to PlayStation
[Music]
I don't know what do you guys think do
you guys think it's Canon
welcome to Jay Pippen's pushings
pardon me sir oh thank goodness when I
heard the bell I thought you were Miss
La Wang know that she deems to come here
though I don't believe I've seen your
face here before either it's my first
time in hogsmead actually is it real I'd
like to think so too
at your service
is Jay Pippin's potions potions for all
ailments
you'll already tell the sign of course
but grandfather always made me say it in
full how may I help you today Professor
Weasley sent me to collect some recipes
I'm new at Hogwarts you're the student
she's in there it's true I haven't
completed the game
I don't know maybe something
contradiction
would want your potion supplies
is it not the most fascinating art
potion making Rivals anything you can do
with a wand I've always said a
lot I'd be that versatile they may not
be as sure as spell work but make no
mistake they are just as powerful they
can heal destroy protect you'll discover
all of this soon enough as it's your
first time in I should mention that it's
not just pushing recipes that sell I
also offer ready-made drafts for all
manner of uses and I unveil new ones
from time to time pop in when you can so
you don't miss out on anything
let's get you those letters shall we
what can I do for you today
a wise decision thank you feel free to
take a look at the rest of my inventory
or come back another time if you're in a
rush today
I hope to see you again farewell for now
good to know
uh-oh steam rules hi Azu
times
foreign
rules are don't judge me for being [__]
at the game
an inquiry ring mind
pardon me sir I'm here for the
spellcroft's professor Weasley ordered
Matilda student
I thought I might be seeing you soon
I am the proprietor here
Thomas Brown I take it you've had the
game has been doing so well I mean I'm
afraid I haven't we're definitely gonna
get some ideas but you will soon enough
it is Magic at its purest creation I can
have something out of nothing of course
it is not without complexity
that is where my spell crafts come in
stay the course
and you can do the same thing even
Professor Weasley hi Luke I certainly
something to Aspire to Mr Brown I look
forward to that day
and I too seen it spell crafts are
incredibly useful for Conjuring unique
items like custom pieces of furniture or
decoration
but I shall let Professor Weasley do the
teaching
for now let's get the spell crafts you
need a potting table and a portion
station yes I believe so sir good
nothing releasing a video out tomorrow
3pm Eastern you want on the Forbidden
Forest have a look
let's look at what we have shall we
for that price
nothing like finding just the right
thing if you're interested if you feel
free to take a look around at the rest
of my Infantry
let me know if there's anything else I
can do to him I'm Slytherin
the magic neap
[Music]
foreign
I honestly haven't played a game
in a long time
oh hello there I don't play a lot of
games these days this kind of got me
back into it
pardon me sir I'm here for the seeds
Professor Weasley arranged for me to
collect oh the Disney for the new fifth
year I take it that's you then Merlin's
beard starting Hogwarts is a fifth year
they positively reeling from it all not
no no I'm open to tips choosing to see
it all as one big adventure but Bravo
not everyone has the temperament to take
things as they thanks Dark Souls Dan
name's Timothy
Timothy there will be the thicker things
if I'm in a way inside now can I hi Luca
I suppose not
in addition to seeds I have plenty of
plants grow everything myself my
specialty is portion ingredients even
Pippin purchases from me but we'll say
we get you a packet of ditney seeds
let me guess you're after something
fresh
fun fact Disney is what Hermione uses to
heal Ron after they operate from the
um Ministry
that's everything better go and find
Sebastian
[Music]
where else should I go
yeah
if you guys enjoy this stream please
give it a like
hi Rita
foreign
hi Dylan yep yes I do
and I'll own it
oh
Emerald silk robe
butterbeer does have alcohol
um that's why winky is able to get drunk
from it
but
it would take a lot for human
I'm actually uh doing a video on that on
my extra Channel
so if you guys didn't know have an extra
Channel called Harry Potter Theory extra
with uh shorter format content
full of mistakes in my
stream notes perfect
thank you thank you
I officially have all of my supplies
excellent
do you get what you need
Ed I did
so I suppose the world is our oyster now
let's see what else we can get up to
uh oh
my
God do I do I die yeah comment in the
chat
brought away from the building away from
the village
foreign
lumos
that's right you must really comes
hey that wasn't so bad
me and Star Wars Theory are friends and
we made the channel together
did you two take on a fully grown troll
by yourselves
suppose so
it's all a bit of a blur to be honest
Merlin's beard are you all right we are
and we were glad to help I'd say help is
a bit of an understatement that wasn't
so bad like that
the makings of an aura if you ask me if
you are unharmed perhaps the two of you
wouldn't mind helping me put a few
things back to where they were of course
officer singer officer singer and thank
you again I haven't read Percy Jackson I
tried
wasn't for me honestly maybe I don't
know I don't know what it was I just
couldn't get into it
he wants
Rebellion
revelio
repair
thank you thank you
where did this guy want me to go in here
rebellious
foreign
tea first
what's up
this thing for officer singer to worry
about
apparel
I'm gonna get the loot
um
repairing things reminds me of uh
Dumbledore fixing slughorn's house
repairer
where's this last thing I have to repair
apparel ah
yes the hill was just singing your
praises
hello sir I don't believe we've met
allow me to introduce myself Augustus
Hill Clothier extraordinaire
I should like to thank you for your
remarkable bravery in fighting those
trolls and not to mention your help
restoring hogsmeade to its rightful
State I was happy to help I've got a
12-inch uh Dragonheart string with the
but I can offer you something a bit of
you much more
are some unique items that afford
certain protections as it were
life-saving protections and as I suspect
this won't be your last dangerous
encounter I'd like to give you one such
set of robes in thanks for what you did
today
thank you Mr Hill that's very generous
of you it's
bitst I can do now let's try this on for
science shall we look at that haircut
plenty for your perusal today take your
time
I'd say that looks as if it was made for
you
you won't be disappointed
foreign
I'd say that I agree with you perfect
three broomsticks is just this way
foreign
Rebellion
yeah maybe I'll just come back
assuming it isn't oh it's a Bedlam in
there he might even meet sirona the
owner she's a good one to know
so I guess uh when do we learn the
disillusionment charm
you said you could get to the child when
they came to hogsmeade they're all you
needed was a distraction I gave did I
miss a scroll in the shop I just watched
a student
take down your distraction
is this child what are you not telling
me
all you need to know is that if you
cannot get to the child then you have
you have no value to me
oh let's go
did they see us I don't think so what
was that Goblin doing with Victor
Rookwood
vanrock is working with Rookwood
the Goblin from The Daily prophet
I knew I'd seen him somewhere
thanks brick
quickly let's get inside the three if
you guys enjoy the stream please like it
should I go back to that shop
I shall let you know if I hear anything
thank you sirona you be well
now what can I oh
there's a face I haven't seen before
first time
man welcome
butterbeers on me
heard about the attack I shall be
looking in on the other shopkeepers and
residents shortly glad to see you two
escaped injury thanks to this one
single-handedly took down a troll is
that right
well done
thanks for this my pleasure
I will say
trolls in hogsmeade
that's never happened before
something's not right
the only brutes we usually have to deal
with
thanks Raven
yes it is was that a lot Gog I saw
leaving just now
your clientele's not what it used to be
sirona not to worry Victor once the two
of you leave the caliber of my clientele
will greatly improve
I wouldn't do that if I were you
Theophilus come now
no need for theatrics
I'm only here for this one anyway
my friend is enjoying a well-earned
butter beer only want a quick word
perhaps you didn't hear me
I said my friend is busy
one would think you all had enough
Bloodshed for one day
come the office
the three broomsticks isn't what it used
to be
let's take our Guardians elsewhere fun
fact Victor Rookwood is related to
Augustus Rookwood the Unspeakable and
Death Eater
seems you've made an unfortunate enemy
what's your back Rookwood and Harlow are
worse than any troll you might encounter
trolls vanrock and Rookwood
what are you not telling me
I promise to tell you everything
it's perhaps best I'll do that later
and on that note I think we should head
back to the castle
oh don't mind if I do
foreign
got it
love the music in this game
Rebellion
I'm certainly glad sirona was there
told you she was one of the good ones I
can see that she didn't seem at all
intimidated by Rookwood and Arlo I think
you'll need to tell me why Victor
Rookwood has you in his sights but we
can talk later for the moment we should
return to the castle Professor Weasley's
certain to hear about the troll attack
soon if she hasn't already don't want to
risk another detention for getting back
after hours
foreign
thanks a lot
I'd like to go back and play some of
those old
you know
Playstation One Harry Potter games at
some point
come and see me I've discovered
something in the locket we found at
Gringotts
foreign
Rebellion
revelio
how far along is everyone
foreign
so ignatia wildsmith
created flu powder for those unaware
that's her there
but
Rebellion
hi Royal Avenger
foreign
please remember to like it
just give me one second
you wish British people were real
okay
professor I'm glad to see you and I you
thank Merlin you're in one piece I heard
about the attack trolls in hogsmeade sir
you guys want to learn more about Merlin
who is it had that dark blue Canon the
dragon color then check out my video
brand Rock used it to control the dragon
but now
and why send trolls too they were there
because of me I overheard ran Rock
talking with Victor Rookwood ranrock was
in hogsmeade with Rookwood the trolls
were ranrock's distractions so that
Rookwood could get to me and he would
have had sirona and the patrons at the
three broomsticks not intervened
great news indeed if Ryan Rock's goblins
and dark Wizards are after you they want
what we found in that vault
speaking of the Vault do you think that
randrock is working with any of the
Goblins at Gringotts I do not Gringotts
goblins aren't typically the friendliest
of beings but they have a great deal of
integrity and
I dare say after what happened to that
poor Banker the Goblins at Gringotts are
no followers of ramrock yeah the voice
isn't great they're off to the locket
you said you discovered something in it
yes
yes I discovered an inscription when I
read it aloud this map appeared
clever enchantment
it's a map of Hogwarts to be sure but I
do not know where it leads
it leads to the library I'd like to play
it through and then make a bunch of
videos on all of the parallels fit
Beyond
I see choices of magic there on the map
I suspected you would see something
shall we go I appreciate your enthusiasm
and I'm eager to discover it
as well but if our experience at
gringons let alone what happened to
Miriam taught me anything iwpc the path
we're on is terribly dangerous
I'd like you to work with Professor
Hackett a bit before we continue but sir
how dangerous could the library be
perhaps we're only after a book perhaps
we are only after a book but we should
be prepared for anything once you've
honed your defensive magic further come
and see me
I'll let Professor Hackett know to
expect you revelio
good night furrios
oh
what's this Polyjuice
revelio
oi can you help me hello were you
calling me I was yes thought you might
be interested in joining me for a bit of
an adventure following a treasure map to
be precise
slight respite from battling the old
troll I should think ask poppy if she'd
be interested as well but couldn't drag
her away from her puff scheme I found
two maps lying about both leading to
locations around Hogwarts care to have a
look at one
let's do it following a Hogwarts
treasure map Count Me In oh wonderful
Hogwarts fascinates me you can keep
whatever treasure lies at the end of
your map I'll be Satisfied just knowing
where it leads
why do you suggest I search first hmm
based on a cursory review of your map
I'd suggest somewhere near hackett's
classroom
very well I shall take a look if I can
find the time fair enough meet me back
here if you find anything Joshi
my ski twist
revelio
foreign
stop it peeves you'll get us in trouble
handy resource indeed your Field Guide
enough
Rebellion
I wonder
foreign
this is where Dumbledore died
not a spoiler
Rebellion
what are you up to now
what do we have here
foreign
yeah this is where he died
yeah Dumbledore would be nine in this
timeline assuming it's 1890 because I
think the developers change their minds
on that
thanks for the kind words experiment
foreign
look at that
come on
oh
Rebellion
thanks Mr dodo
uh tomorrow at 3 P.M Eastern uh the
history of the Forbidden Forest is
coming out
ah a rhinoceros skeleton
it's only a new student would help me
with my side
I'm here about the new spell you wanted
to teach me Professor look at those
robes a professor fig indicated a
certain
urgency to you competing your defensive
magic assignments as such you are to
learn incendio the fire making spell
handy for lighting torches burning away
spider webs and when necessary defending
against those who would wish to do it
and send you sounds versatile
what but before we get started I'd like
you to complete a few tasks you may be
surprised by some of them
astonishing how much students don't
think their professors know when you're
finished come and see me then we shall
begin working on and send you
you know where to find me once you've
finished
revelio
I agree it's uh there's too much to do
it's it's overwhelming at the moment
but I'm sure most ones isn't a secret as
it's believed to be
convenient travel was before I invented
blue Powder
kind soul help me
repair them
no the game was 1890 originally but they
removed that date from the game maybe
just so it wouldn't contradict Canon so
now it's just late 1800s
but I think it's 1890.
Rebellion
foreign
what's up
Rebellion
can I help you
Sebastian told me to see you about a
club if Sebastian vouchers for you
that's all I need to know I coordinated
deals for crossed once oh okay
invitation early so you must have really
I'll go back to the searching
I seem to have a knack for dueling
how does cross ones work exactly you
I'm actually with other dualists and
whoever is still standing in the end
wins
determining the school's greatest
duelist once and for all and to liven
things up the winner is awarded the
prize
interested if you enjoy the stream
please give it a like
of course
Julian's an entertaining Pastime I agree
besides in crossed ones you could deal
with a partner if you like
it's time I'll pay you a Sebastian
Bust or Jewel alone so care to step into
the ring
get me in the ring
begin
we'll make you regret signing up
foreign
nothing
perhaps one day I'll sign up for a round
nice work Sebastian wasn't wrong about
you there's strong competition ahead but
keep this up and thank you thank you
School Champion brilliant Count Me In I
shall
part one should be available
um I don't think I named it part one
though just go to my streams I don't
have many spell combinations come and
see me and I'll set it up again
congratulations on your hello Albus
Percival Walford Brian Dumbledore
what a name
no I'm not on story
hello Lucan is the next round of crossed
ones all said why yes it is I've got a
great match lined up ready for another
round
I'm ready let's do it
yes Sebastian then let's get to it
ready to get thrashed
this gonna go well or no
lumos
thank you
love yourself
too easy
Bravo I gave it my all you
eat the
Oh They'll really have it in for you
you'd better keep practicing if you want
a chance at winning
or at least surviving the next round
what's the next round
is it four people
the next round is
around this I've always said that travel
broadens the mind
revelia
revelio
Rebellion
I'll stream for like another half an
hour
um but I'll probably stream tomorrow as
well
hello Lucan may I use the training dummy
that would be wonderful Beast B should
cost all your
Slaughter dummy lands if you need to
stop practicing before you finish all of
them let me know
lumos
love yourself
Slytherin yeah
okay okay getting the hang of it
you'll be a fearsome Challenger now
assignment's all finished
[Music]
a young friend
my my
hmm
no I haven't read Percy Jackson I tried
I did it just wasn't for me
seems I'm out of the tournament you
could have gone a bit easier on me
perhaps I should stick to potions
I'm not on story
yeah I just want the coolest looking
cloak that's what's most important to me
rapero
revelio
help me with my sad predicament
Rebellion
revelio
I just sprattleby was a belly
accommodate you and that you found
success in your endeavors rebellious
foreign
I finished all of the tasks you gave me
Professor Hackett glad to hear it
then you should be ready to learn and
send you
should be Professor thanks Nick much
appreciated I visited enough care
colleagues it's Among Us
sure you that fire is a Fickle servant
you'll spell spellcasting has impressed
me thus far but please maintain Focus I
would rather be not in today's lesson
with your robes aflame let us begin and
remember focus on the proper wand
movement
concentrate and keep your wand steady
which uh spell do I swap it with
probably repairer right
good work
and send it
[Music]
what's up
here love yourself incentive he's such
things
some kind soul help me
foreign
revelio
there's the fountain
where do I go for this one
stairwell
once I've exited the courtyard
rebellious
let me listen
definitely going for the dark approach
you've got to
handy resourcing
I'm most pleased
back here
Rebellion
oh
here we go
foreign
what are you up to now
there's a daily and keys are back aren't
they brilliant
oh can you the square button okay let me
have a look
oh
thank you thank you
if only a new student without
Rebellion
I think I've got to start using the flu
powder
ah there you are
there you are hello sir you'll be
pleased to know that I worked on my
defensive magic with professor hackard
so I hear she tells me you've taken
rather well to your new wand you must
continue to work with her and your other
professors to improve your skills that
said I don't wish to postpone our visit
to the library any longer
so shall we proceed
big I have work for you come I don't
know how I feel about that with a
student in my schedule
indefinitely as well too easy
I would think that after all the trouble
you caused me with ozric you'd be eager
to make amends
my office five minutes
that man is exasperating
unfortunately our trip to the Restricted
Section will have to wait a bit longer
but Professor we have no choice
it would be unwise to provoke our
illustrious Headmaster further I shall
find you when I've completed whatever
toils I must endure okay thanks for the
tip
talk to Sebastian
okay
Sebastian mentioned sneaking into the
Restricted Section
perhaps he'll have an idea
revelio
you can't imagine
how does this work
[Music]
foreign
I'll come back to it
could look up a guide but I won't do
that
yeah it doesn't seem important right now
you are there you are
promised me an explanation for what
happened in the three Broomsticks not
many students please like the stream
folks if you enjoy
since he's working with Round Rock and
man rock is after something I found at
Gringotts ramrod and when were you at
Gringotts Professor fig and I ended up
there after the dragon attack it's quite
the tale fig had this portkey pork key
to Gringotts I'm not sure I follow I
barely follow myself and I was there
anyway we ended up in an ancient Vault
where we found a map that map leads yeah
definitely don't get it you can't be
serious deadly serious hello
why not tell a soul about any of this
probably said too much understood your
secret's safe with me
whatever it is thank you Sebastian
you mentioned being clever enough not to
get caught in the Restricted Section and
I am
meet me outside the library tonight and
tell no one
thank you Sebastian I'll meet you later
foreign
see there
that's the door we need to reach
and those annoying prefects would love
nothing more than to Rattle us to
Scribner so don't let them see us
understood I can be sneaky let's go hold
on now
there's a spell you should know the
disillusionment church ah good good good
forgetting places you're not supposed to
be
cast it and you'll appear as little more
than a trick of the light just as long
as you keep your distance and stay quiet
you mean I'll actually be able to turn
invisible something like that it's not
as foolproof as a cloak but those are
expensive and spells spells are free
give it a try
foreign
what should I swap it for
[Music]
we must remain
unseen
[Music]
foreign
's still here quick behind the bookcase
you told me the librarian would be gone
by now
usually but it'll still be all right do
you see a desk behind me
the key is in the drawer of that desk
now here's what we're going to do I'll
create a distraction to draw her away
you focus on getting the key I'll meet
you outside of the Restricted Section
you distract I get the key understood I
said I'd get you in and I always keep my
word trust me
there the library's closed until morning
someone there must have been one of the
books wandering about
oh that one's Charmed to look more
useful than it is fooled me twice never
judge a tone by its cover I say
I'm gonna get the loot
ghost don't let her see you
simple
oh that was cool
I was talking about
so what is it you've been looking for
I'm looking for a cure to help my twin
sister and so that she can return to
Hogwarts
because Merlin knows everyone else has
given up why do you think we'll find a
cure in a Restricted Section does the
Hogwarts matron have nothing that can
help out
no we've tried everyone from nurse
blaming to Saint mongos
but I can research on my own no need to
concern yourself with that right now oh
let's focus on what you're after
which is what precisely I'll know it
when I see it
you're being awfully cryptic
foreign
hello I'm going to tell I'm going down
oh blasted peeves I've got to stop him
or at least get to the librarian with a
good excuse for all of this
how do I know you won't go to the
librarian and blame this all on me why
would I do that
having friends who are in my debt now go
good luck in your search
now where is that damned Poltergeist is
creepy in this
just the spell to repair this armor
Revenue
who loves peeves
comment
of course traces of ancient magic
there must be more to this room
foreign
cringe
me
Revenue
am I this lead
okay
I hit him
oh
revelio
[Music]
ah I need to wake up that room
I wonder if I can hit the room
foreign
that was simple
thanks Leonard
I'm still uh coming to that conclusion
myself Brandon
I need to play it some more but I'd like
to think so I'd like to think that it's
Canon
oh surprising God's at the ready
love yourself
the idea is to play the game through and
then make a bunch of videos
um comparing the lore
Thanks Martin
still very new to streaming so getting
used to it
self
foreign
Sunday
[Music]
oh do you have to go on it and then keep
choosing it
no no no I like the I like the tips no
tricks that's for sure
oh
I don't know why I found that so
difficult
it shouldn't have been
this must be the way forward but to
where
nope
foreign
why is this so difficult for me
oh no
is getting bad
one hit at a time okay
oh okay
I was uh doing too much there I see
it's a deal
ouch
lumos
moves
revelio
whoo
stressful it is a book after all
[Music]
yeah still getting used to it
certainly no expert yet
just watch the Harry Potter movies then
then run through Fantastic Beasts
and then there's also some extended lore
published online
what did everyone think of the Fantastic
Beasts films
foreign
I know they weren't particularly well
received but I enjoyed them
not nearly as much as the
originals but they're good
yeah I agree
please uh like the stream guys if you
enjoy
I like this cutscene
[Music]
this very dumbledore-esque
I have a 12 inch
um Dragon heart string made of you
wanted to see me I had mistress it's
very flexible Professor Rackham this is
the door uh Morgan Arch welcome
Professor Rookwood professor of a car
we understand that you are adjusting
well to life at Hogwarts
I am
I am glad
especially in life of your unusual
situation starting as a fifth year
as it happened I was also admitted to
Hogwarts as a fifth year
I've never heard of another like us miss
morganock
when we spoke yesterday after class you
asked about the beautiful swirls you saw
years ago when we visited your Hamlet I
recognized you all immediately I cannot
thank you enough for what you did we
were glad to help and yes I did see
swirls of magic everywhere that day my
father insists it was My Imagination
Running Wild but it was certainly
real it was not your imagination
Percival
Professor Rackham can see them too but
we have never known of another who could
I don't understand what are they The
Whispers or traces that appear when they
yeah reminds you of uh Morgana of
ancient magic
ancient Magic
you are capable of wielding it Hogwarts
itself is a stronghold of ancient Magic
so if I can see traces of ancient magic
does that mean I can wield it too with
the proper training but let us not get
ahead of ourselves
before I can train you to wield such
Magic
you must first master all that Hogwarts
has to offer
a magic this powerful can do great harm
in the wrong hands must be by a
selective of you oh I'm getting tired
such we ask that you not speak to anyone
about what we have discussed here today
foreign
sneaking in the Restricted Section again
do I need the uh dissolution
she definitely had a certain look on her
face there I'm not sure what that was
about afraid I must take this to the
Headmaster
but is that being said peeves informs me
that you didn't come alone tonight
someone has coerced you I would have you
tell me
you're a bright boy
don't waste this
looks horrifying
oh Sebastian
what will your uncle say
[Music]
open another adventure are we
foreign
yeah he looks terrifying
oh
hi Lewis
I'm going to start using these uh
using this flu powder
foreign
okay I'm done for the night guys
everyone have a good night thanks for
tuning in I'll uh I'll be back tomorrow
probably uh tomorrow night
thanks for all your help